my name is Roger Cornell I'm explosives
engineer
all right so right off the bat there's a
lot of gunfire
you see holes being ripped into multiple
fuel tanks
essentially just the perfect environment
to start some sort of combustion process
so you can see that there's at least
some source of flame under the hood of
the engine bay man that explosion is
just ridiculous we just saw bullets
ripping through almost every fuel tank
there those tanks they no longer have
any capacity for holding pressure which
will prevent the reaction from
accelerating and turning into something
violent like this and I know it's the
rock but no one is just gonna walk away
from that thing the villain in this
movie is essentially trying to create a
distraction so he's thinking that by
lighting the fuel source of an
automobile on fire that he can somehow
create this explosion and that's gonna
distract everyone inside he takes a rag
inserts it into the gas tank to get it
so gasoline and then you'll actually see
him take this combustible material and
use it to cover up the actual gas cap so
that no gas vapors can be exposed
the big issue with the scene is the fact
that I can't see why the gasoline would
actually go through an explosive event
even if you have a flame that exists at
that gas cap interface there's no reason
for it to travel into the tank I would
expect the flame to just sit at that gas
cap and just continue to burn until
there were no more gaseous or gasoline
vapors to pull from you would
essentially just have a giant car candle
in order to actually get it to explode
if I had to do it I would try to seal up
that gas tank as best as I can and if
you put a flame underneath that gas tank
if you started heated up increase
pressure to the point that it ruptures
and then all of that would light up and
create somewhat of an explosion
so James Bond movies are typically
filled with ridiculous scenes that just
are completely non-physical I said
doesn't time fly the watch that was just
thrown is one of the gadgets that James
Bond got from Q I believe but you can't
have this does it do anything supposedly
it's filled with some sort of energetic
material and it can be used as a
detonator it tells the time
there's no device that can be that small
and yet that potent to actually knock
someone out of their chair throw them
across the room there's certainly a lot
of fantasy but at least there's some
cool physical elements within the actual
flame production that we see the one
advantage that this scene has is I'm
pretty sure there's no CGI or limited
CGI here you can see the black smoke the
black that you're actually seeing is sub
production essentially carbon in the air
if you look into the fireball you can
see these liquid jets of fuel being
propelled into the air when I saw like
the fuel shooting I was like ah this is
definitely real it took a lot of work
magnificent isn't she the explosion is
almost perfectly symmetric starts at the
center breaks down the legs at the same
rate combustion events like this
especially if it's an accident they're
unpredictable there's a million factors
there's a lot of physical considerations
to take in a place you can bet that
there were charges that were timed in a
very symmetric fashion so that the flame
looked exactly as it does here
[Music]
this poor poor man has been given
essentially suppository used by convicts
to hide money and drugs filled with c4
which is a really commonly used
energetic material it's been inserted
into him this is gonna get a little dark
what do you got the human body is
actually a really great tamping
mechanism we're made of water and we
have pockets of air and both of which do
a really good job of dampening out
shockwaves the guy would just have a
really bad day and don't get me wrong he
certainly be dead but for the most part
there's no reason a fuel tank would
explode if you had that amount of
material it just wouldn't do that kind
of damage
way too much flame explosions way too
big
he shoots a bullet into the concrete to
get this this trail of fuel to start
both don't spark unless you have very
very specific rounds this wouldn't work
at all if I had a guess what would
happen if you actually were able to
light that trail of fuel I'd imagine the
car would just sit there and burn it get
hot it would burn for a while it might
melt some of the surrounding structure
and that's it the fact again that
there's fuel on the ground tells me that
the fuel tank is ruptured there's no
real mechanism for building pressure in
that combustion system